the League of Legends all-star events
have given us some pretty unforgettable
moments and whether it's game changing
plays or hilarious out of game
shenanigans we're bringing you the top
10 all-star moments in League of Legends
let's check off the list with double
lives pentakill from the 2013 all-star
not only was it the perfect way to end
the series between rival regions and a
and EU but the korean casters went crazy
classic
let's move on to something out of gate
our number nine spot goes to shop for
her display of spot-on cosplay and fire
rhymes take it away
sonic wait won't listen now cause was
back was right loosen he hit the cue the
kick and more but it wasn't enough to
settle the score for ice ice what
happens when you stick to of the
goofiest players meu onto the same
computer and they lock in Leeson a lot
of laughs apparently as hooni and Kasim
trolled it up during the 2015 tandem
boat listening to their comms as they
stumble through the game is
side-splitting matches performance in
the 2016 all-star 1v1 tournament was
memorable
taking down faker and pray before losing
to maple but what sticks in our mind is
this hilarious moment where maple cuts
down Mata after their Yasuo showdown
oscar-worthy superior rune set as well
takes down Mata on its own
[Applause]
folks that's what we're talking about I
love it PDD was already a legend in
China but when he laid down quite
possibly the best Rumble equalizer of
all time in front of his home fans in
Shanghai you can imagine the crowd went
crazy easily worthy of number six
[Applause]
channeling their inner Michael buffer
- and advised back-and-forth intros for
the 1v1 at all-star 2016 deserves number
five on this list from classic styling
to creative name calls the Mach showdown
delivered on comedy and entertainment
his opponents playing for Team fire
North America's dam Master General and
clg's man with a plan put your hands
together for
so we're cheating a little bit with this
one since technically it happened before
all-star 2013 but the famous 1v1 between
soaz and wicked to decide who would
represent Europe was a huge moment
wicked stream of the showdown pulled in
a hundred and forty thousand viewers
with so as emerging as the winner
so as went on to make his region trout
winning the toppling skills showdown
over shy baits in perfectly and he picks
up the victory the french eastwards
crowd has a reputation as one of the
best in the world and they held nothing
back when paris hosted the all-star
event in 2014 the pantheon chance
led by casters million chips is the
stuff of legends spot Daniel
okay so one accidental snowball trip
into the enemy fountain is unlikely that
is a victory that is a kill
you chose the snowball chose your own
death but - that's all-star magic in
action double dips and Dragons reactions
alone are worth number two on the list
there it is
twice in a row what is the possibility
absolutely amazing one of the most
influential plays of all time the insect
is a clear pick for number one and yes
it happened at all-star
nice throw the rest of the
but dad comes in behind jealousy fusion
Ward's back kicks in that is so hard to
execute all-star has given us so many
unforgettable moments it was really hard
to narrow it down just to ten so which
moment was your favorite definitely let
us know in the comment section below
it's time to make building your
champions easier introducing the score
eSports is new builds calculator which
allows you to plug in items and runes to
figure out which build gives you the
best stats the new builds page also
gathers information on what the top
players and your favorite pros are
building so you'll be able to try them
out yourself take control of your
champion and try out the new feature on
the score a sports is builds website by
clicking on the link in the description
below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button